I'm talking to mr.
Burke who was the charge hand marker often
the bridge workshops sydney harbour
bridge where luna park stands. Do you
remember first getting the job. Them's the
pain. Yes i happened to be one of the first
of the markers are employed there. And
as the staff grew in numbers. I was invited
to become the charge can and from then
on until the completion of the marking off.
I had charge of all the marking off on
the main span work. The large angles
a huge play. The gusset plates in which
every hole. Had to be marked in its proper
position before the material were sent to
the big drilling machines and then from
the drilling machines to the publication
shop where the anglers in the place were
bolted together. Finally river did and send
out on the site. Do you mean. Where you
got your instructions from your drawings
from now what. Where did you get your
drawings from from the
door my long gone along as
a draftsman and we had some very good
template makers to who helped us with.
Wooden templates in which the majority as
a whole which were marked for the big ngos
and so on. We saw the bridge going from
day to day. What was the main
part of what you actually did
. Well as the men working for me marked
the hole in the various angles and
plates. It was my responsibility
to check them. Check every hole
that they marked before the angler some
place were sent to the drillers and i can
virtually cross the bridge today and
suggests that i've had my ruler on every one
of the holes that those rivets fill up.
That's an incredible achievement i reckon.
Considering the accuracy as well. Everybody
from the from the riveters on on up the
line says how remarkably accurate every
every rivet hole was. Yes or that so and
of course there wasn't anything particularly
exciting about that was plane down to
business and making sure that everything
was correct and if you want to know why an
experience i've had which was probably
a culminating experience
of my work i was invited
to go across to the harbor in
a ship. You know about and
go up on the crane. To
the top of the chords. That
day before they were joined i
had the privilege of standing with one foot
on the north spain and one foot on the
right spot and with about an
inch an hour half in between and
a day or so before they were lit up. That
was my most exciting despair and the
other was playing down to work. Did you.
Do you have any trouble while you were
turning these large plates in the
shops. No it was a matter of having
a very careful check in
a case neared fire and our two there did
go on wrong or something and the careful
checking pointed this out and or bracing
for may before the place went to the drill
now had those plates been wrong where
they had holes running along the cord
up to the diagonals up to the verticals
had anything happen to those plates. They
were irreplaceable in australia at the
time it would have meant that had been
rolled again and england and send out
and remarked so the. The importance
of making sure everyone of those holes
were correctly mark speaks for itself.
Were there any ones out that had to be
dumped where they're not to my knowledge.
Nothing at all and end talking to some
of the men who worked on. The riveting.
They said that we quote we mark result did
a good job because i didn't have to re ima
a whole. Yes it's true. Is everybody says
that but i just came across one bloke was
on the night shift. Who said that on
a couple of occasions they had to dump
stuff in the harbor later on and. I don't
remember that i know nothing about but i
can't speak about it or i don't know as i
know anything was bought it was not used.
There was nothing done avert it. Can you
remember the layout of the workshops.
When you were working there. Yes. When i
commence out it was almost
like coke floor. And
there were some huge logs. Going
along the length of the shop
and it was only the blocks were made for
the ngo's to rest to be marked off.
It was
a dirty really fraud because as we
tramped up and down the length of the
chords than the length of the
angles. So the ash was accumulating
nambour allowed the dust first flying up
and it wasn't ordered over and of course
the dogs were impregnated
with something to keep the
why don't say what creosote
or something and that had
a horrible smell to that was early on of
course. Do you member the other working
conditions that you have any time off for
a smoker or anything like
that. Now of course we're in
a day when member expected to work eight
hours and do eight hours work not like
they do now where they'll get time off for
morning tea and afternoon to we had no
morning and afternoon tea permissable
but i think some of them found out
a way to stick around somewhere and have
a cup of tea. Yes i heard various stories.
Yes particularly young apprentices
do you remember anything they used to
get up to. Well one of them said to me
a few weeks
a diary said all you ever did to me was to
to say get there but our out of it. And
he's ours probably
a nuisance to you and i said you probably
make some of the grey hairs that i've got
. Some of the stories about crown and anchor
boards in learn share it all sorts of
things like they do everything levitt
now i can't really i was particularly
friendly with one young english fellow
there and we frequently had our lunch
together and discussed other things
and. Bridges and boats and not so
at that time to our studying advertising
and commerce allowed in which people would
finally finish my working career and
so we had other things to talk about.
Humor his name. Do you as frank tinker as
he did. Now is here and you know i didn't
see him at the commemorative luncheon
whether he's still in sydney or not i don't
know. I can't see as name on
a near the list anyway. Do you remember
also when i was talking about the layout of
the workshops you member how. The steel
came in and how it moved down the shops can
you describe the shops to me. Yes. Outside
of the shop proper. There was the war
where all those big steel girders
and anglos were unloaded.
And they count round on far east mostly
into the shop and then lifted up by
the travelling cranes and put into the
positions we wanted them for marking the
whole journey of the plate mangels and the
planing machines. Remember the planning
a machine and this friend of mine
fronting he worked the planning
machine
a very huge. Plane and it's
in their material up to my
level joints and all that
sort of thing. Doing with
a guillotine. Yes the guillotine was
quite near where we had our marking off
benches and we heard
a roar about coming down every say or had
an up boat place to their outlets and
stars. That pretty noisy. Yes they
were the guillotine was very noisy
understand some of the plates were two and
two were two inches thick silicon steel
. Yes yes i know these places are said
before. Helen from england and i don't think
they were able to be manufactured in australia
so that was all the more reason why
we had to be very particular in marking
the holes. For the various spirit as it
were attached to them. Did you ever get
taken out on site of perth and the time
when you enter the joining of the urge. No
never. Where did you live at that time.
How did you get to work. I was living it
right by that time and used to come in
from rose by to cars street
walker acquire street and pick up
a launch for took us however to the north
side to the workshops and that's fairly
handy. Do you remember more on the working
conditions what was it like when it was
a when there was
a southerly down by the workers very
very cold. We. We mostly had overalls on
and we wore hats. Most of the time because
that research cold and we made sure we
had good winter underwear when we were
through the winters was anything to keep you
on their differ from work. No not was
impermissible anyhow i think some of our
fellows managed to be or up
a little or her prior were suddenly here
and they'll do you remember any accidents
well you will let you remember any
accidents in the workshops will be
.